sinkende zahlen bleibende sorgen wegen
der mutierten corona varianten verstärkt
deutschland einreisekontrollen vor allem
aus tschechien und tirol lockerungen nur
schrittweise im zdf-interview präzisiert
kanzlerin merkel die inzidenz zahl von
35 einigung auf lieferketten gesetzt die
koalition will deutsche unternehmen dazu
verpflichten dass auch ausländische
zulieferer menschenrechte und
umweltstandards einhalten
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend wir kommen an
diesem freitag zu den nachrichten deren
sportlichen teil norbert lehmann dabei
hat 29 durch wir beginnen verhalten
positiv die korona zahlen gehen weiter
kontinuierlich zurück der shutdown und
die hygieneregeln zeigen wirkung
deutschland sei auf einem guten weg sagt
denn auch lkw chef wähler heute auch
wenn es zu früh sei um entwarnung zu
geben
große sorgen bereiten nach wie vor die
ansteckenden virus mutationen aus
großbritannien und südafrika
und so sehen die aktuellen zahlen aus
9860 neuinfektionen registrierte das
robert koch institut innerhalb eines
tages das sind gut 3000 weniger als
vergangenen freitag 556 menschen sind in
verbindung mit cupid 19 gestorben
auch die sieben tage incident dance
sinkt kontinuierlich heute liegt sie bei
etwa 62 zur corona lage ein bericht von
britta spiekermann zwei kitas
geschlossen kreis bergstraße in hessen
hier haben sich 63 menschen infiziert
wahrscheinlich die meisten mit der
britischen variante b 11 7
dort waren betroffen sowohl
erzieherinnen und erzieher als auch
eltern von kindergartenkindern aber die
größte zahl bildet bilden die kinder
alle sind in quarantäne
die virusvariante sehr viel ansteckender
in deutschland gehen sechs prozent der
positiv getesteten fälle auf die
britische variante zurück allerdings die
zahlen sind schon eine woche alt neue
bundesweite daten soll es erst in den
nächsten tagen geben in bayern liege der
anteil der mutation schon bei über zehn
prozent sagen infektiologen wir gehen
natürlich davon aus dass es so wie auch
in anderen ländern in europa der fall
sein wird diese varianten zu nehmen
werden wir müssen die ausbeutung der
varianten zumindest verlangsamt
schon bald werden in vielen
bundesländern kitas und grundschulen
ihren betrieb wieder aufnehmen
es ist ein risiko und es ist eine
abwägung das zug um zug schule und kita
öffnen mit klugen konzept mit konzepten
auch des schutzes vor infektion
das ist wichtig denn kinder und familien
und junge menschen werden durch diese
pandemie besonders belastet die
regierung greift zu harten maßnahmen
damit sich virusvarianten nicht weiter
verbreiten
deswegen haben wir in der
bundesregierung gestern beschlossen
tschechien tirol und die slowakei zu
virusvarianten gebieten zu erklären für
diese gebiete gilt ohne ausnahme müssen
vor der einreise nach deutschland tests
gemacht werden
es besteht eine pflicht zur quarantäne
quarantäne und testpflicht das sind ganz
konkrete folgen
an mehreren grenzen zu unseren
nachbarländern werden corona kontrollen
ausgeweitet
schauen wir auf österreich das
bundesland tirol offiziell mutations
gebiet der grund vor allem die schnelle
ausbreitung der sogenannten
südafrikanischen virusvariante für die
menschen die raus wollen aus tirol
gelten drastische beschränkungen mehr
dazu von britta hilpert
das gab es noch nie an einer
innerösterreichischen landesgrenze
ausfuhrkontrolle für tiroler an 44
stationen rund um das bundesland tirol
muss man beweisen dass man kürzlich
negativ getestet wurde
nur dann darf man raus minuten dauert
der test und ja auch immer bin mit dem
dieser besser eingrenzen kindern für
mich schlicht in innsbruck sind läden
und friseure geöffnet man merkt kaum
dass in tirol die südafrika mutante
grassiert trotz der gefahr verweigerte
tirol den lockdown die freiheit nach
innen wollte die landesregierung die
abschottung von außen ist der preis
dafür ein run auf teststation erlebt
tirol deshalb nun und ärgert sich dass
von bayerischer seite vor einem zweiten
spiel gewarnt wird
vielleicht ist daher söder nicht über
alles genau informiert aber es hat
trotzdem eine konstruktive beiträge hat
wie mir die mutationen besiegen können
dann herzlich willkommen heute machen
deutsche grenzer noch nur stichproben ab
sonntag wird jeder kontrolliert tirol
ist virus mutations gebiet das heißt bus
und bahnverkehr wird größtenteils
eingestellt und wer nach deutschland
will braucht registrierung negativen
test und gute gründe auch pendler dann
auch mit dem richtigen testergebnis noch
einreisen dürfen ist noch nicht klar
und dann blicken wir jetzt nach
tschechien ab übermorgen wird auch an
dieser deutschen außengrenze verstärkt
kontrolliert ganz tschechien gilt als
mutations gebiet aktuell melden drei
grands bezirke mehr als 1000
neuinfektionen pro woche auf 100000
einwohner
gleichzeitig hat das parlament den
landesweiten corona notstand nicht
verlängert weitgehende lockerungen sind
deshalb sehr wahrscheinlich wolf
christian ullrich im krankenhaus von
sokolov nahe der deutschen grenze ist
corona alarmzustand normalerweise kommen
hier zehn krankenwagen an tag an jetzt
sind es 50 wegen der besonders
ansteckenden britischen virus mutation
wurde der landkreis heute abgeriegelt
das ist jetzt diese maßnahmen gibt sehen
wir als zeichen dass man begriffen hat
was hier gerade los ist
an den grenzen der drei am stärksten
betroffenen landkreise soll nun streng
kontrolliert werden damit sich die
mutanten nicht weiter in tschechien
verbreitet aber manche bürgermeister
wollen die regel nur locker umsetzen
wir fangen jetzt nicht auch noch die
leute auf den feldern an und fragen
wohin sie fahren obwohl die
infektionszahlen in tschechien eine
dritte welle andeuten hat die opposition
dafür gesorgt dass der notstand am
sonntag endet ein politischer protest
gegen die korona politik von
ministerpräsident barbisch der
gesundheitsminister hofft nun auf die
landräte
die landräte werden jetzt von sich aus
lokalen notstände erklären so dass wir
am ende wieder da sind wo wir mit dem
nationalen notstand waren
kopfschütteln bei den bürgern in den
nachbarländern hält man sich an strikte
regeln aber diese nation ist leider
unbelehrbare auf deutscher seite sind
jetzt die arbeitgeber alarmiert sie
fürchten dass tschechische pendler wegen
der neuen einreisebeschränkungen ab
sonntag in der deutschen produktion
fehlen
wir müssen im schlimmsten fall wenn wir
keinen ersatz finden eine anlagen eine
anlage komplett stilllegen die korona
mutation wird ein neuer schwerer schlag
für die wirtschaft in den grenzgebieten
es gibt vieles was die bundesregierung
in dieser pandemie erklären muss ist zu
wenig impfstoff eingekauft worden warum
gibt es keine klare perspektive für
einzelhandel hotels und
kultureinrichtungen vor allem in diesem
punkt hat die bundeskanzlerin heute
etwas klarheit geschaffen
im zdf interview stellte sie öffnungs
schritte in aussicht räumte aber auch
fehler in der krone politik ein
nicole diekmann angela merkel setzt ihre
informationsoffensive fort und erläutert
warum die inzidenz 235 nutzt stärker im
mittelpunkt ihrer politik steht nach dem
öffnen der friseursalons soll der
einzelhandel dazu kommen und dann ein
stufenplan greifen sofern die inzidenz
von 35 stabil bleibt stabil stellt
merkel heute klar bedeutet mindestens
zwei wochen lang
wir haben dann drei stränge im grunde
noch wir haben die schulen in den
höheren jahrgängen berufsschulen unis
wir haben die privaten kontakte als
zweiten strang wie viel mit wie viel
menschen darf ich mich treffen und wir
haben einen dritten strang das sind im
grunde die kultureinrichtungen kinos
theater gruppen sport und dann auch die
restaurants und eines tages die hotels
merkel wiederholt die selbstkritik aus
ihrer gestrigen regierungserklärung man
sei im herbst zu zögerlich mit
beschränkungen gewesen
beim thema impfen aber sieht sie
lediglich fehler in der kommunikation
ich will gar nicht drum herum reden es
gibt eine enttäuschung und vielleicht
hat diese enttäuschung etwas damit zu
tun dass ich es erstmal faszinierend
fand dafür überhaupt einen impfstoff
haben nach weniger als 1
das ist eine riesenleistung damit konnte
man nicht rechnen und dann wir nicht
ausreichend darauf hingewiesen haben
dass am anfang nicht für jeden gleich
der impfstoff da ist ein weiterer und
neuer baustein im kampf gegen korona
selbsttests auch den vorwurf dass
deutschland in diesem punkt hinterher
hängt will die kanzlerin nicht stehen
lassen
wir haben jetzt die ersten anträge auf
zulassung bei unserem hersteller bislang
keinen antrag gestellt wir haben sie
jetzt schon zugelassen in österreich zum
beispiel und wir haben im corona
kabinett darüber gesprochen und da war
die frage wollen wir prüfen wie wirksam
sie sind oder lassen wir sie einfach zu
rund zwölf minuten lang stellte angela
merkel sich den fragen zwölf minuten in
denen sie ihre politik erklärte für sie
war und sie verteidigten das
ausführliche interview mit der kanzlerin
sehen sie heute abend im heute journal
um 22 uhr in unserer zdf heute app
können sie sich das gespräch jederzeit
anschauen und die wesentlichen aussagen
auch noch einmal nachlesen
klar geregelt ist wer in deutschland
zuerst geimpft wird
doch in mehreren bundesländern haben
sich amtsträger wie kommunalpolitiker
oder geistliche vorgedrängelt und impfen
lassen wohl mit übriggebliebenen
impfdosen gesundheitsminister sparen
will nun sanktionen für solche fälle
prüfen
außerdem müsse verbindlich geregelt
werden wer überschüssige dosen bekommen
soll
auch die deutschen flughäfen sind massiv
von der korona krise getroffen
einige kämpfen ums überleben die
bundesregierung plant deshalb ein
umfangreiches hilfsprogramm 600
millionen euro sind für die 15
wichtigsten flughäfen vorgesehen 200
millionen sollen zusätzlich von den
jeweiligen bundesländern kommen drei
ministerien haben monatelang gestritten
den kompromiss nannte arbeitsminister
heute einen durchbruch für die
menschenrechte
die rede ist vom geplanten lieferketten
gesetzt das große deutsche firmen
stärker in die pflicht nimmt sie sollen
in allen phasen der produktion und auch
bei den zulieferern im ausland darauf 8
dass menschenrechte und umweltschutz
eingehalten werden sonst drohen
bußgelder
andreas huppert
kinderarbeit stadt schulunterricht
hungerlöhne statt angemessener bezahlung
obendrein noch die zerstörung der umwelt
so sieht das arbeitsleben für millionen
menschen in entwicklungsländern aus oft
im auftrag von zulieferern auch
deutscher firmen um das künftig zu
verhindern hat sich die bundesregierung
nach zähem ringen auf ein sogenanntes
lieferketten gesetz geeinigt
es geht um die einhaltung von
menschenrechten in globalen lieferketten
und damit um menschenwürdige arbeit
made in germany steht zukünftig noch
mehr nicht nur für beste qualität
sondern auch für globale verantwortung
der wirtschaftsminister hat lange auf
der bremse gestanden fürchtete dass
lieferketten gesetz schade der
wettbewerbsfähigkeit deutscher
unternehmen
natürlich ist es mir als
wirtschaftsminister auch wichtig dass
die deutsche wirtschaft am ende stärker
nicht schwächer da steht
wohlfahrts und umweltverbände
kritisieren dass vielen einer
zivilrechtlichen haftung um zb vor
deutschen gerichten gegen unternehmen zu
klagen
das würde auch dem deutschen
rechtsempfinden eigentlich entsprechen
dass jemand der durch die verletzung
seiner sorgfaltspflicht negativ
betroffen ist die möglichkeit hat zu
klagen
wir sehen mit diesem entwurf ist
lieferten gesetz keinen unterschied zum
business as usual von heute wo deutsche
unternehmen für
menschenrechtsverletzungen und für
umweltschäden an der länder
verantwortlich
deutsche unternehmen müssen künftig mehr
auf menschenwürde und nachhaltigkeit
achten dass lieferketten gesetz ist
dabei ein erster wenn auch kleiner
schritt der bundesrat ist heute zu
seiner tausendsten sitzung
zusammengekommen
zu diesem anlass hielt bundespräsident
steinmeier eine rede vor den vertretern
und vertreterinnen der länder
der bundesrat stabilisiere die
demokratie sagte er und betonte wie
wichtig der föderalismus und die
zusammenarbeit von bund und ländern sei
besonders während der korona pandemie
der bundesrat hatte sich am 17 september
1949 in bonn konstituiert gleichzeitig
mit dem bundestag
der grüne ministerpräsident von baden
württemberg winfried kretschmann
will im landtagswahlkampf etwas kürzer
treten wie er bekannt gab es der grund
dafür die krebserkrankung seiner frau
er brauche zeit um ihr beizustehen und
werde nicht alle termine wahrnehmen
können in baden württemberg wird am 14
märz gewählt dass wir versuchen uns so
gut es geht gegen korona zu schützen
wirkt sich auch positiv bei anderen
infektionskrankheiten aus so spielt zum
beispiel die grippe in diesem winter
bislang kaum eine rolle
zum vergleich wurden in den ersten fünf
wochen 2017 fast 43.000 influenza fälle
im labor bestätigt waren es in den
ersten fünf wochen dieses jahres gerade
mal 100 29 melanie hug berichtet in
diesem ärztezentrum in erfurt ist die
wintersaison eine andere kaum patienten
mit grippesymptomen im wartezimmer
influenza gab es hier bislang fast gar
nicht in den jahren davor war das
deutlich mehr wir haben ja ein richtiger
influenza epidemien gehabt mit ganz viel
erkrankungen auch todesfällen ganz
vielen das ist dieses jahr überhaupt
nicht der fall
bundesweit gab es noch nie so wenig
bestätigte grippefälle die ursachen
hierfür sind der schatten und die aha
regeln außerdem haben sich in dieser
saison besonders viele gegen die grippe
impfen lassen die impfung habe zudem
effekte auf die korona infektion weil
sie das immunsystem trainieren erklärt
matthias preetz es gibt zb eine sehr
gute studie wie ich finde aus brasilien
bei knapp hunderttausend patienten und
da hat man gesehen wenn man sich im
gleichen winterhalbjahr in dem die
korona infektion aufgetreten ist vorher
art grippe impfen lassen war die
sterblichkeit um 20 prozent reduziert
dass die grippe aufgrund der niedrigen
zahlen völlig verschwindet scheint
illusorisch
man kann eigentlich nur aus rücken denn
der mensch der einzige wird ist es bei
den pott muss er gut gelungen aber bei
influenza wissen wir eben dass neben den
menschen auch noch viele andere
säugetiere und auch vögel betroffen sein
können und hier hat ja erreger ein sehr
großes reservoir aus dem man sich immer
neue regeneriert
deshalb wird wohl auch corona so leicht
nicht verschwinden so bleiben uns beide
erkrankungen vorerst erhalten
die jazz welt hat einen ihrer ganz
großen verloren der amerikanische
pianist und komponist schickeria ist im
alter von 79 jahren gestorben
in seiner langen karriere verband korea
den jazz mit dem letten mit dem rock und
der klassik er arbeitete mit legenden
die miles davis und herbie hancock
zusammen
carey nahm mehr als 100 platten auf und
gewann 23 grammys so viele wie kein
anderer jazzmusiker
[Musik]
tja und nun zu den erfolgen der
deutschen skeletonis bei der heim wm in
altenberg nach vier von sechs medaillen
haben wir heute gut bei den männern hat
christopher groth er seinen
weltmeistertitel verteidigt bei den
frauen tina herrmann die knapp vor ihrer
teamkollegin jacqueline learning gewann
für zieler hermann steht das vierte wm
einzelgold sei 2016 fest als die
olympia-zweite schafft linie enttäuscht
durchs ziel gefahren ist hermann hat
zuvor nach einem schwachen ersten lauf
zeit aufholen müssen
das gelingt ihr am ende liegt sie elf
hundertstelsekunden vor lölling dritte
ist die russin yelena in die kino
hauchdünn vor sophia griebel auf platz
vier
christopher brot her noch ohne sieg in
diesem winter kommt mit 2 lauf
bestzeiten noch an dem führenden russen
alexander tretjakow vorbei und wird wie
im vorjahr weltmeister große jetzt
ebenfalls wie im vorjahr ein großes team
kollegen alexander gast nach der chef
des organisationskomitees der
olympischen spiele in tokio schiro mori
ist zurückgetreten der 83 jährige zog
damit die konsequenzen aus seinen
frauenfeindlichen aussagen
mehr als eine woche hat es gedauert dann
bot yoshinori seinen rücktritt an
medienberichten zufolge hatte sich der
frühere premierminister bei mitgliedern
in japans olympia-komitee beschwert
sitzungen mit vielen frauen dauert
länger und sein zitat nervig die
gouverneure in der präfektur tokio
yuriko ok sagte der neue olympia chef
müsste jetzt zeichen setzen für vielfalt
und harmonie
wer das amt übernimmt steht noch nicht
fest die um ein jahr verschobenen spiele
sollen am 23 juli beginnen
alexander zverev hat bei den australian
open in melbourne das achtelfinale
erreicht durch einen souveränen sieg
über den franzosen adrian mannarino
mannarino
alexander zverev geht dieses
drittrundenmatch leichter von der hand
als gedacht der hamburger bestimmt von
anfang an druck und tempo spielt seine
stärken aus nach 6 zu 3 im ersten satz
gewinnt der weltranglisten siebte auch
den zweiten mit 6 zu 3 gegen seinen
französischen gegner danach marinos
gegenwehr vollends gebrochen
mit einem ass zum 6 zu 1
es wäre auf dieses spiel und steht nun
im achtelfinale gegen dusan lajovic aus
serbien und bayern münchen darf sich
jetzt auch fußballweltmeister nennen ein
einziges tor reichte für den sieg bei
der klub wm in katar gegen den
mexikanischen zivilisten tigers-manager
war erzielte es in der 59 minute
das ist der sechste titel für die
münchner in einer saison
und das hat bisher nur der fc barcelona
geschafft
toll ich habe auch noch was wintersport
ist er manchmal mit einem gewissen
aufwand verbunden keine höhen hat ein
bastel in lettland gescheut 170 meter
bobbahn eine große runde im eigenen
garten schon fast olympiareif sechs
jahre hat der tüftler an der bahn
gezimmert jetzt passt alles wert ob das
eis und das wetter ein entspanntes
dahingleiten eine familie aus lettland
vielleicht die einzigen gemütlichen
bobfahrer der welt so würden wir das
auch spaß machen
eisige kälte und viel sonnenschein
erwarten auch uns morgen ob und wann es
milder wird erfahren sie gleich von
beste intelli so viel von uns danke für
ihr interesse
das heute journal mit marietta slomka
und dem interview mit der kanzlerin um
10 und wir sind morgen wieder der punkt
7 19 uhr einen entspannten abend
wünschen wir tschüss
[Musik]
ein kunde und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter über deutschland gibt es fast
überall eine schneedecke sehen ist hier
in weiß im norden und westen gibt es
einige grüne flecken hier da ist die
schneedecke tatsächlich aufgebrochen und
auch im süden da liegt verbreitet schnee
richtung erzgebirge dieses
verschwommenen hier
das sind wolkenfelder das war heute der
fall unter 1 hoch das löst jetzt immer
mehr die wolken auf und so gibt es in
der mitte deutschlands viel sonnenschein
dieses hoch ist dafür zuständig 1045
hektopascal hat es heute erreicht in der
nacht verschwinden die wolken ebenfalls
nur richtung erzgebirge gibt es
schneegriesel aus einer dichten
hochnebeldecke im süden gibt es viel
wind sonst zeigen sich die sterne bei
sehr strengen frost bis minus 20 grad in
der mitte minus sechs grad an den küsten
ja und morgen viel sonne im westen oder
auch im süden sogar an den küsten und im
osten etwas mehr bewölkung insgesamt
trocken bei höchsten temperaturen von
minus acht grad in der mitte und +2 grad
ganz im westen sonne satt gibt es dann
am sonntag bei minus fünf bis plus fünf
grad und am mutter kommt von westen
gefrierender regen auf ein schöner abend